[Música]
porque vienen los inmigrantes
aquí no cabemos todos eso es una de las
frases que escuchamos muy a menudo
cuando se trata de hablar de las
migraciones no eres de aquí porque tu
nombre no aparece en ningún registro
civil pero tampoco eres de allí porque
te fuiste
es una de las frases también que las
personas inmigrantes convivimos con ella
a lo largo de nuestra vida yo soy de
camerún un país situado en el corazón
del continente africano me muere un
lugar donde se vive se respira y se
sueña también a los siete años soñaba
con ser periodista como mi hermano mayor
que es un referente para mí recuerdo que
me ponía delante de un espejo en mi
cuarto y miraba fijamente a un punto
simulando la los informativos soñaba con
ser corresponsal en zonas de conflictos
para poder visibilizar el sufrimiento de
la población civil pero quería también
será alguien útil para ese mundo y eso
pasa evidentemente por tener una
formación
yo estudiaba en mi país a pesar de que
en aquel momento no se valoraba mucho
los estudios me presenté a un concurso
para optar por una beca de estudios para
ir a quebec
y después de tanto esfuerzo la
administración decidió vender mi plaza a
otra persona este suceso hizo que empecé
a hacerme muchas preguntas acerca de mi
futuro empecé a plantearme la idea de
salir de mi país no sea así es como
salgo de mi país sin decirle
absolutamente nada a nadie ni siquiera a
mis padres porque yo me fui dirección
cumplido los 15 años recuerdo que antes
de ir me puse delante de mi casa durante
media hora estaba llorando antes de
emprender un viaje que tenía por destino
nigeria y que acabó convirtiéndose en
una odisea que me pudo costar la vida
tuve que cruzar en este viaje la
frontera en nigeria níger argelia y
marruecos antes de llegar a españa uno
de los momentos más difíciles sin duda
fue la travesía del desierto de sahara
para poder llegar a argelia recuerdo que
estuvimos cuatro días cruzando el
desierto sin comer sin beber
deshidratados porque durante el día hace
mucha calor y por la noche hace mucho
frío en el desierto y al tercer día uno
de los compañeros y brian cuando nos
levantamos para seguir el viaje le
despertamos y él había fallecido lo que
hicimos fue enterrar le con la arena y
seguir el camino
a lo largo de esa odisea yo he llegado a
pensar que mi vida nos servía
absolutamente para nada
porque sufrimos una continua
deshumanización vemos cómo se vulneran
nuestros derechos en cada etapa el
proceso migratorio
estuve después un año sobreviviendo
en el monte gurugú en marruecos y el día
que llegamos a la valla de ceuta melilla
para intentar entrar por la valla
recuerdo que uno de los chicos que se
precipitó para saltar la valla se quedó
enganchado entre las cuchillas y vino la
policía por detrás y le tiró de la
pierna
después de eso volvimos a intentar
varias veces hasta que un día
conseguimos entrar y la policía a través
de una revolución en caliente nos
devolvió a los militares marroquí
volvía a intentar por la parte de ceuta
y pude entrar nadando a través de la
frontera del tarajal
ese día cuando llegamos a la frontera
había un caos entre la sirena de los
coches de policía
los disparos de pelotas de goma de la
guardia civil y la gente que gritaban en
el mar porque recibían golpes
ese día recuerdo que llegué inconsciente
a la orilla porque la ola del mar es la
que me echó fuera porque recibí varios
golpes en la cabeza por parte de la
marina real marroquí después de eso
estuve un año viviendo en el ceti de
ceuta y a continuación me llevaron a una
cárcel para inmigrantes en tarifa que
son los síes es en esa en ese sitio pasé
los peores días mis peores días en
españa
estamos ocho personas en una cárcel en
una celda de apenas diez metros
cuadrados
ahí es donde teníamos que hacer nuestras
necesidades y por la noche venía la
policía y se llevaba a una persona
esposada esa persona ya sabemos que no
volverá porque le van a deportar a su
país
después de 60 día en ese sitio me
dejaron en libertad y me mandaron a una
ong en almería yo seguía teniendo la
idea de retomar mis estudios
ahí es donde pasó algo que marcará mi
vida para siempre
cuando elige al director de esa ong que
yo quería seguir estudiando él me dijo
claramente riéndose que a quien había
visto que ha venido como nosotros
venimos y que haya haya podido estudiar
que yo no podía hacer eso que yo tenía
que ir a buscarme la vida en los
invernaderos o en los campos en almería
esa respuesta me chocó muchísimo porque
lo que yo quería era seguir estudiando
entonces empecé a ver que ahí tampoco me
podría realizar tuve que plantearme la
idea de abandonar ese sitio así es como
a través de un amigo llegó a córdoba
y los primeros días evidentemente cuando
llegue ese amigo no estaba y estuve los
primeros tres meses durmiendo en la
calle porque no conocía a nadie hasta
que dos familias respectivamente me
acogieron esas familias no sólo me
abrieron la puerta de su casa sino que
me dieron mucho amor y mucho cariño
porque muchas veces la persona
inmigrante es lo que necesitamos como
seres humanos un poco de cariño por
parte de la gente esas familias se han
convertido en un referente para mí en
españa porque me permitieron también
seguir con mis estudios porque tuve que
empezar de cero porque mis expedientes
de camerún no me convalidaban allí y hoy
en día estoy estudiando relaciones
internacionales gracias a esa familia y
también gracias a la universidad loyola
andalucía
mi historia es la de mucha gente que de
un día a otro lo dejan todo en busca de
un futuro mejor y hay también gente que
se ven obligados a salir por conflictos
o por catástrofes naturales pero
desgraciadamente la emigración nunca se
ha hablado de la inmigración desde un
punto de vista positivo nunca se ha
hablado de la inmigración como algo
natural al ser humano como algo que ha
existido a lo largo de la historia de la
humanidad
hemos visto como en españa se ha pasado
de acoger el barco acuario es el verano
pasado a impedir la salida de lo penal
para poder rescatar las embarcaciones
que están a la deriva en el mediterráneo
hemos visto también cómo se está
criminalizando a la gente que se dedica
a salvar vidas en el mediterráneo
nos llegan noticias todos los días sobre
las muertes en el mediterráneo' estamos
hablando de más de 15.000 muertos en los
últimos cinco años en la frontera sur de
europa esto está pasando a escasos
kilómetros de nuestras casas pero
miramos hacia otro lado porque se nos ha
acostumbrado a la cultura de la cifra
al fin y al cabo los que mueren son
africanos son migrantes no interesa
absolutamente a nadie el día que hubo el
atentado de saliendo en francia ese
mismo día se hundía una embarcación con
70 migrantes en el mar pero nadie habló
de eso todos los focos mediáticos
estaban en parís una vez más los medios
de comunicación volvieron a demostrarnos
que hay muertes que valen más que otros
estamos viviendo una de la mayor
involución en materia del respeto de los
derechos humanos en la frontera sur de
europa por eso tenemos que empezar a
poner nombres y apellidos y saber que
detrás de cada inmigrante que muere en
el mediterráneo' hay historias hay
familias y hay sueños que la política
migratoria represiva ahoga en el
mediterráneo'
no venimos aquí por gusto a la muerte
créanme nos salimos de nuestros países
porque queremos morir nuestro continente
sufre desde hace siglos de un expolio y
una explotación que le mantiene
arrodillada áfrica es la región del
mundo que posee el 30 por ciento de los
recursos naturales del mundo
y hoy en esta sala donde estamos casi
todos tenemos algo en nuestro bolsillo
que viene del continente africano que
son nuestros móviles porque para tener
esos móviles tiene que venir el coltán
expoliado del congo explotando incluso a
niños en minas de coltán en condiciones
de esclavitud el congo para que os
hagáis una idea posee el 80 por ciento
de los recursos de la reserva de coltán
del mundo
y según un estudio realizado por el foro
internacional por la verdad y la
justicia en áfrica
el yacimiento de los recursos naturales
del congo podría superar el pib anual de
los eeuu y de toda europa occidental
juntos y esta es la gran paradoja es la
gran paradoja de un continente tan rico
y con gente empobrecida y además de eso
existe un control sobre la economía de
esos países actualmente hay varios
países africanos que utilizan una moneda
que hoy en día es conocida como francos
de la cooperación financiera en áfrica
pero antes eran francos de las colonias
francesas de áfrica esa moneda se
fabrica en francia y según los
economistas fan y pillo y dongo sanz
vacila en su libro el arma invisible de
la françafrique explicaba que esa moneda
fue creada en 1945 después de la segunda
guerra mundial por el general de gaulle
para que los países africanos
participarán en la reconstrucción de la
metrópolis
con esa moneda francia ejerce de facto
un control sobre la economía de 14
países como camerún senegal costa de
marfil y malí es decir que francia
controla la vida de más de 150 millones
de personas os imagináis un país
africano controlando la economía de
europa desde el banco central europeo o
desde o controlando la economía desde la
reserva federal estadounidense pues eso
es exactamente lo que pasa con esos
países africanos y además de eso tenemos
la falta de vías seguras para que los
africanos puedan migrar muchas veces nos
dicen por qué no venís legalmente porque
no coges un vuelo para venir ojalá
existieran esas villas para poder migrar
porque como podéis saber si un español
quiere ir a senegal tan solo tiene que
comprar un billete de avión y se va a
senegal sin embargo si un senegalés
quiere venir a españa tiene que pasar
por toda la traba burocrática y al final
se le acaban de negando el visado
y si decide quedarse en su país tampoco
lo puede hacer porque no se puede
realizar ahí porque una actividad como
la pesca que es la que sustenta a muchas
familias en senegal está vendida a las
multinacionales occidentales sobre todo
españolas que están ahí haciendo pescas
industriales es decir la gente autóctona
de senegal que toda la vida han vivido
de la pesca de un día a otro se dan
cuenta de que su gobierno corrupto y
corrompido ha vendido la exclusividad de
esa actividad a una multinacional
occidental
es decir esa es la realidad de la
relación que hay entre áfrica europa que
en muchas ocasiones no se habla cuando
se habla de la relación entre áfrica
europa desde aquí solo nos hablan de la
cooperación al desarrollo en la
cooperación al desarrollo es sólo la
punta del iceberg que se ve en esa
relación pero la parte sumergida es la
que no interesa que sepamos en áfrica
tanto la política la economía o la
educación están todavía colonizados a
través de un neocolonialismo con nuevos
actores como china que mantiene todavía
arrodillada a ese continente y que
obstaculiza su desarrollo
cambiar eso está en nuestras manos está
sobre todo en manos de jóvenes africanos
porque nadie vendrá a hacer eso en
nuestro lugar
áfrica tiene voz cada vez a través de
sus jóvenes alrededor del mundo
nuestra lucha puede no verse porque son
pequeños pasos lo que estamos dando pero
pasos firmes y seguros recuerdo que
nelson mandela estuvo 27 años en la
cárcel para poder acabar con el régimen
de la parte eduardo galiano s/a en una
frase que mucha gente pequeña en lugares
pequeños haciendo cosas pequeñas pueden
llegar a cambiar el mundo
y en esta lucha esperemos que el coraje
de thomas sankara la sabiduría de
camerún a la resistencia de partes
lumumba y la resiliencia de winnie
mándela sean nuestros faros
gracias